the swiss army knife himself craig
stamen comes into tonight's game with a
5-2 record with a dazzling 2.71 e-r-a
he's been one of the many arms out of
this bullpen that has carried the load
this season for the padres
aguilar into left field there's a base
hit first hit of the night for the
marlins and their first base runner one
out in one on for east sandias coming up
second baseman payoff pitch from stamen
is popped up
back behind short drifting back is
cronin worth and that's going to fall
then the throw to second gets away
and the marlins catch a break
at first glance honey it looked like
cronenworth backed off either hearing or
assuming that tommy fam was going to
make that play right now the hottest
marlins hitter louis brinson pats with
two on and one out here in the first
stamina again in o2 pitch and princeton
goes out of the way loops one to right
going to get down for another lewis
princeton head around third aguilar
sprinting toward the plate there won't
be a throw brinson knocks in the first
run of the night it's one nothing
marlins two down two on jorge alfaro
first appearance of the series as he
gets to start in left field tonight for
the marlins
long look at diaz at second here it
comes from stamen this one is fair down
the left field line and toward the
corner diaz is going to score brinson
coming around third he will be in easily
and jorge alfaro with a two rbi double
the marlins up three nothing
so brinson and alfaro knocking in the
first three of the runs of the night one
one pitch leone breaks his bat and
grounds one deep to first base osmore
almost on the outfield grass has it
flipped to stamen and the top of the
first inning ends the way it began with
a three to one put out in between all of
that though the marlins get three runs
on four hits they also leave a man on
the bound for the marlins already with a
three-nothing lead before he throws his
first pitch is braxton garrett really
heavy on the changeup the overall
numbers here opponents hitting 304 a
good thing for the left-hander he's
allowed two earned runs or fewer in each
of his five starts this season another
good young arm in the marlins
organization in there for strike three
called knee-high inside corner for the
first out of the night
one-two pitch a swing and a miss he's
got back-to-back case to begin this one
now he's ready the left-hander deals and
the 2-1 pitch hit hard on the ground
fair down the third baseline kind of
ricochets back into shallow left field
alfaro will pick it up and fire to
second it's off target and he's on his
way to second and he will get there
standing up so runner on second two outs
for jake cronin north lefty to lefty
kronerworth hits into the air to right
field that ball is back and it's off the
wall
machado is coming around from second
throw is off the mark it's an rbi wall
ball double for jake groninger and the
padres are on the board so two down
corner worth at second here's a line
drive basin into center field off the
bat of nola here comes crossword that's
all the way to the track and the wall
it's three to two it's an rbi double for
nola and the padres are back within a
run a good answer here in the bottom of
the first inning for san diego again a
no two pitch to hosmer a swing and a
miss he struck him out with a slider so
three strikeouts in the first for
garrett but three hits lead to two
padres run
one on one out here's miggy rowe
round out to hosmer at first his first
time up
and now a base hit into center field
sierra will round third he'll come in to
score
and rojas with an rbi single lots of
early runs on both sides tonight it's
4-2 marlins with one out in the second
1-1 pitch hit on the ground to shortstop
cronenworth's got it little flip to
frazier one on to first plenty of time
aguilar barely halfway there as the side
is retired he grounds into his team
leading ninth double play of the season
marlins get a run on a couple of hits
but nobody left first and third nobody
out and here's o'grady
and a ground ball right side diaz would
get a second tough play there nice play
by rojas ruttle score meyers in the back
door and it's a one-run game again now
4-3
on 1-1 there's a bouncing ball right at
the second baseman nissan's got it on
the first for the out that ends the
inning so the padres cash in a couple of
base hits they push across another run
two balls no strikes on jory
and jorge has a couple of hits
two rbi doubled his first time up and
then it's went into right field for
eight lead off base hit in the fourth
that is strike three leon could not pull
the trigger but it's the second
strikeout for miguel diaz
line drive to short cut by chronower
throwback to second a double play oh boy
i don't know what el faro was doing but
i do know he's out and the inning is
over
struck out in the first inning with
three k's for garrett hurt in a string
right now which he has retired six
padres in a row gonna settle into this
outing and hosmer drives one towards the
gap in right center field and that's
gonna get in to the track and the wall
hosmer
into second base with a gap or double
good start to the bottom of the fourth
inning for the padres base is loaded
nobody out 2-2 pitch a swing and a miss
a slider up he's down on strikes huge
out the first out in the inning so now
bases loaded one out for fam audrey's
down a run in the bottom of the fourth
inning
bounces away here comes hosmer game is
tied
four to four in a wild pitch
myers moves to third grisham to second
hosmer comes in this game is square at
four 1-1 pitch on the way fam hits a
hard ground ball to third base
backhanded by anderson coming home the
throw is wide meyer scores everybody's
safe 5-4 padres their first lead of the
night austin adams pitcher number four
tonight for san diego we saw austin last
night in the ninth he struck out the
side to secure the 8-3 victory
enters his 49th game and the numbers are
really good on the ground softly hit
machado on the run and in time two down
not an easy play guess what he made it
look easy out number two now the big guy
in the box here's the two two pitch
swing and a miss a one two three sixth
inning for austin adams and he caps it
with a kid
miguel rojas who had an rbi single in
the second he's one for three tonight
has the season average of 274 right now
that is a fair ball and headed toward
the corner and right here comes sierra
getting the green light around third
throw is
not in time and miguel rojas comes
through ties it up in the seventh with
an rbi double two outs and runner at
second austin nola coming up
lying to left field at a base hit from
second base coming around to score is
frazier padres back on top six to five
austin nola drives him to
opposite field and a base hit
for anderson over to play it is myers
getting it back in quickly but a two out
single for brian anderson so we have got
an injured pitcher as leaving this game
is through pomeranz
as he base hit to right field doesn't
seem to favor anything it doesn't seem
to grimace at all
second save opportunity for melanson
more than an inning this season
on the ground to third base machado's
throw
that's the ball game
mark malanson gets a four out save as
the padres hold on and wins six to five